the Joe Rogan experience but I do love
that you know that's why I travel to
amazing stories isn't it people living
in so many different ways big beautiful
world lots to see lots to do and that's
why you know a lot is so of Madagascar
upon it up with the lemur Network
conservation I've got 60 organizations
on the ground helping to protect and
preserve the unique biodiversity so with
these expeditions is almost the the
record is like the enticement and
motivation but if but if I can do
something worthwhile and highlight
certain issues
so with Mongolia I was actually raising
awareness about climate change and the
effects that has on the nomadic way of
life gets so cold out there now that the
livestock struggle to survive which
means that the nomads are out of work so
they move to the capital city Willem
Botha to find work but there's now like
a good district ooredoo its district you
know that white felt sense a rut
surrounding the capital city and it gets
free is one of the coldest capital
cities in the world it's cold they Boone
what they can a lot of its dirty cold so
the clean coal gets sent to China and
plastics so there's now a smog that
covers the capital city it's a difficult
place to live in the winter only and
babies are lasting three four days after
birth before that suffocating oh my god
just from the burning plastic and yet
just difficult to breathe and the doctor
just says evacuate the city
get yourself should try my best to raise
funds for the Red Cross raise awareness
of actually Mongolia you don't here go
to that picture again make that extra
large a look how crazy that way of life
is yeah there's all these tents
everywhere in the background you see
looks like some wall tents but maybe
some hard structures it looks like
there's a few harbors there yet there'll
be different huts that just be most of
them are just tents yeah there's one
building back there a multi-story
building scroll back go this is there
see that one yes Ellen Botha so you have
more even even in the center you know
pretty pretty nicely developed in there
but it's crazy right all dirt roads and
what are they doing with sanitation and
sewage yeah again
I don't like hearing that noise yeah oh
they lack access to drinking water
proper sewage and
internal heating yeah many are reluctant
to leave behind the unique millennial
old way of living yeah just [ __ ] in a
hole in the ground whatever whatever
forever yeah so it's imagine you imagine
so these were all way to go yeah these
were all out in the wilderness and the
Mongolian wilderness it's absolutely
stunning but they've been forced pretty
much to move eeeh so in the camp mates
stop that please go back up and make
that larger again what is that a
background city what is that a capital
city of Mongolia Willem Botha Wow all
that stuff on the outside is mostly
people lives - yeah yeah so you can buy
it jobs - like - what - 40 Fahrenheit
[ __ ] and amen and so they just need to
stay alive so they burn whatever they
can they can find stay warm Jesus so
there's always you know always
environmental up my heart first and
foremost especially see in the world you
see and it's Rorty you know you're out
madagascar trekking this wilderness an
80% of all plant life and wildlife found
in Madagascar alone it's about nowhere
else in the world really literally
walking past stuff on the daily basis
thinking you'll not found anywhere else
only only native to Madagascar giant
comet moths this big bright yellow -
lemurs over a hundred different species
so I do my best to try to meet up with
as many organizations as I possibly
could it will happen to protect and
expand national parks who were helping
to educate the local supply different
means of work protect the species living
within highlight like the press were
interested in the journey but I would
direct and highlight you know the real
unsung heroes I call them the people
volunteer and doing this day in day out
and how often is just a lot of you
switch on the TV and it's just all
negative isn't it but I believe
positivity spreads more positivity so
I'll highlight these issues all of the
amazing work is doing their utmost to
protect the environment and yeah that
makes you want to do more as well
doesn't it you know yeah well is it
seems like it's gotta change your just
your frame of reference shifts you've
seen so many things that most people
haven't seen just haven't been to that
place and knowing that there's mass of
groups of people that are living like
that that are burning plastic and the
wintertime to try to stay alive
it just shifts how you view things
that's it for sure yeah and you know
once you've seen it you can't unsee it
right it's one of those where you just
want to try to keep helping where you
can that's how many people are living
like that oh right so there's four
million people in Mongolia but probably
about three million are in the capital
city probably half of that are ger
districts nomads Wow almost half maybe
so more than a million people in turn
but essentially it's get in that way
anyway yeah and the air quality just
again so poor get imagine that just
giving birth if the doctors forget get
out the city Wow there's a high chance
that you're gonna lose your child and
and the people that this day the the
older people that must be taking years
off their life yeah most likely and then
in the summer side and experienced in
the winter but in the summer you still
got the Gerda Street but it's war we can
see the sky
[Applause]